hi
thank you for talking to me about this
it was so delightful to watch the show i
was a fan of the original and i had no
idea where this was gonna go with things
so i thought it was a lot of fun
thanks
i'm curious for you i mean
with something like this where you
hadn't been familiar with the original
your parents had
what got you know how did you get into
it did you just sort of pick a random
episode to watch it how did you get your
impression of what the original series
was
yeah well i started with the pilot
um
because the
pilot of the original and the pilot of
our show
um
are pretty much parallel in terms of
story um and so it was really cool um
through the auditioning process to have
sort of the knowledge
of the original show um going into each
audition
was it fun to also not
have to be beholden to anything really
specific with the original series since
you're not directly connected to that
you make a comment about how you know it
was a tv show and that's why you have
the nickname so you're not you don't
have to answer to any of that so did did
there
was there like a sense of freedom with
that
um definitely i would say i i felt um a
certain amount of pressure you know
because the original
was so iconic and there is such a vast
fan base for that show
um and so i really wanted to keep the
spirit of the original alive
and do justice to the original um but
also courtney did such a great job of
sort of turning it on its head in a way
and bringing the show into the world we
live in today and because of that um
sort of creating a lot of space for
creative freedom
you're no stranger to leading a show or
playing the title character of a show
so how was doing this show how did it
compare to doing andy mack have you felt
any major differences or is it just sort
of the responsibility
feels greater as you know the older you
get
yeah i mean
i think it's
what's so
hard about it and what's so great about
it is you never get
you know your first
big project again you know and for me
that was andy mack it was my first
everything you know
um and so obviously
doogie was different for me because
it wasn't the first time anymore you
know
and i had much more experience walking
into it
but um there is something so
fun about you know
being a little bit older
and having a little bit more
responsibility
and you know having more experience
coming into it um and also you know
obviously there's a part of me that even
though it's not my first time
experiencing these things it's still
just as exciting as it was when it was
the first time
does that also help you identify with
the character in the sense that you are
in a professional setting and there are
these adult expectations and
responsibilities placed on you and even
though you're not a teenage doctor
you're still
you know at the lead of it definitely i
mean i think lahela's sort of
navigation of being caught between two
different worlds is very similar to my
own experience um like you said
obviously i'm not a doctor but i am an
actor and so i i do have
i think unique insight into
what it feels like and and the very
isolating at times experience of being a
young person
in a professional setting and sort of
having these expectations and pressures
and responsibilities that adults have
but still being a kid
and how to sort of grow up and rise to
the challenge but also
you know create space for you
to be a kid
um so i think navigating that is
something that i have um
pretty vast experience with that i was
able to bring to um portraying lahela
this is a young woman who has a lot of
confidence and her abilities as a doctor
what are the challenges in delivering
that as an actor because you not only
have to show the confidence that she has
but you have to actually be comfortable
with how natural the doctorly stuff is
yeah i mean it was a big challenge for
me uh most of my acting you know as much
as i can
because authenticity is so huge for me i
try to pull as much from my real life as
i possibly can and you know
when bringing a character to life you
know uses much of my
real life experience to create a
performance um and so
with the hospital scenes and with all of
her doctor
stuff i had no personal experience to
pull from i couldn't connect
you know to what it is to
be taking care of a patient or have
someone else's life in my hands you know
those were not
experiences that i was familiar with in
any way and so
working towards creating an authentic
performance was much more difficult
because i couldn't ground it in
my experience in real life
did you have someone there on set to
help you with all that if questions came
up during filming yes we had a doctor on
set
every time we had any hospital scene or
medical scene and i would just you know
drill lines with him or go through
procedures with him or just listen to
him talk about what it was that the
scene was about you know
um and i also did a lot of research on
my own time googling youtubing webmd um
all that good stuff
what do you enjoy most about this family
dynamic because i love the dynamic
between her and her parents and her two
brothers what was it like to not only
have that relationship developed as
characters but also you guys as actors
yeah i mean i think
there is something
so intense about shooting a show you
know that you you become bonded to the
people you're working with very quickly
um and on top of that we were also on an
island together which just
cuts down the population of people
you're seeing by a lot and then on top
of that we were doing it in the middle
of a pandemic so we really only had each
other to lean on um and to rely on and
so we grew really close really quickly
and learned a lot about each other
really quickly um and i think
those dynamics um that we
developed so rapidly off screen
translate on screen and i think really
add to the chemistry and camaraderie um
that comes across on screen
when you have such a beautiful backdrop
to work in is it ever challenging
not to be distracted by the location
that you're in just
for the sheer beauty of what you're
surrounded by
yeah i mean i think in a sense yes
um it is very easy to get caught up in
all of it but i think
that works for the show you know i think
sort of allowing yourself to be
overwhelmed by how beautiful it was
only adds to the show you know because
it's truthful you know when you are
standing on that beach looking at that
water and the sky and the mountains
there is this very overwhelming
experience and feelings
that sort of occur because of that and
in a sense i think being in hawaii and
genuinely experiencing all of that i
think that all really grounds the show
at the beginning of the season
she's trying to figure out how to
balance
you know this professional life with
life as a teenager by the end of the
season do you feel that she will have a
better grasp of that or is it just going
to be a continual work in progress for a
while
i mean
sort of
yes to both questions um i think by the
end of the season you definitely see a
lot of growth in lahela and i think she
has a stronger foundation than at the
beginning um but you know life's a work
in progress i don't think there's any
point in life where we stop growing or
stop learning or stop changing and
evolving and so i definitely think even
at the end um of the season even though
she has grown and matured and learned a
lot there's so much still she has to
learn and experience
have you started to have conversations
with courtney about what future seasons
of the show would explore do you have a
sense of where things might go
i mean we've talked about it
in a very limited capacity um you know i
i try to keep my expectations low so
that they're always being exceeded and
so i don't want to jinx anything or um
or prepare for something that might not
happen but yes we've definitely talked
about it in the sense of just wouldn't
it be so cool if we talked about x y and
z
or or showed lahel experiencing
whatever it meant it may be um so yes we
definitely
both see so much for lahella's character
and for all the characters in the show
um there's so much
untapped that we haven't dove into yet
is there a quality in her or an aspect
of her that you've grown to appreciate
the longer you've played her and gotten
to know her that you didn't necessarily
realize she had in the beginning
that's a great question um
yeah i think
one thing that i really grew to
appreciate about lahella is that she's
incredibly open
um to to learning and to growing and
you know even as a genius you know who
is a prodigy doctor
she's not shut down she she doesn't seem
like okay i've learned everything there
is to know i'm done you know she's very
open to growing and to continuing to
change and ask for help when she needs
it and i think that's very admirable
yeah i think that that's what makes the
relationship with her and her best
friend so fun too because she does go to
her best friend for advice on things
that she might not necessarily
understand even if she could save
somebody's life at work
yeah exactly
well i appreciate you talking to me
about it i thought the show was so fun
it was
i just i love your character i think
she's she's really cool and a great
great role model for kids
thank you so much
thank you i appreciate it